it's time to explore Our Roots
wordsmiths our backgrounds where we came
from because the word I'm bringing you
in this video is
Heritage mind you we're always exploring
our Roots when it comes to vocabulary
huh all right
herit it's a noun it means a Birthright
Traditions or Goods granted to you by
relatives or cultural ancestors for
example I have Lithuanian Heritage
here's a map of the Baltic Sea uh
there's Lithuania some of my ancestors
came from there this this country in
Eastern Europe that's part of my
Heritage let's talk about the derivation
of this word it comes from French many
words in English do because about 900
years ago the French invaded England and
took their language along for the ride
so Heritage is itself of French origin
but we can break that down further into
ER which is a verb that means to inherit
uh to receive something from a relative
and AG which is a noun n forming suffix
it's pronounced a in French in English
it's
pronounced right like an IG you scratch
uh it can turn verbs into nouns for
example turning the verb to marry into
the noun marriage so inherit plus AG
equals the thing you inherit right
heritage heritage so we've got these two
word parts can you think of words that
sound similar to herit and Ag and
uh that use those word parts I'll give
you 10 seconds to come up with a few
doesn't have to be a lot okay commence
the
music here are some that I came up with
inheritance which is the property you
inherit when someone dies a ANC is
another noun forming suffix wreckage is
a noun it's what's left left after
something has been wrecked right the
remnants of something that's been
destroyed we took the verb to wreck to
destroy and added AG G to make it a noun
to make it
wreckage an heirloom herro and air he i
r are related words and an heirloom is a
treasured piece of inheritance that
passes down through a
family let's use the word heritage in a
sentence or two ot's family heritage was
writing his mother is a screenwriter and
his grandfather was a playwright it's a
family tradition for him you
see there's a there's his mom and
there's her dad this is also a
typewriter for those of you too young to
know what a typewriter is it's the
machine that goes clicky cacky clicky
cacky ding ding ding you make the words
feel like that's
self-explanatory so that's being used
for an individual or a family right a
family context ad's family but let's use
it in a wider National
context many foods that we think of as
uniquely American originated elsewhere
but we can claim Cajun chef Paul prum's
turducken a chicken stuffed inside a
duck stuffed inside a turkey as part of
our cultural heritage here I have drawn
a handy cutaway diagram you see and here
in the middle that's the chicken this
purple layer here represents the duck
and of course this outer layer the
mantle of the Earth represents the
turkey and this represents a hungry
individual who wishes to eat the
turuan but more to the point what I'm
trying to say is that the truckan
represents something that is unique to
America it is part of the United States
cultural and culinary Heritage it's part
of our food Heritage now I have never
had the buck wild pleasure of eating a
truckan uh but I hear it is delicious so
support your local mad scientist chef
wordsmiths and I'll catch you next time
you can learn anything daveid out